okay so so you don't like to lose if in
this case you are not successful in you
know the board
does not accept your offer you've said
you won't go higher is there a plan b
there is
all right we're live breaking edition
sean just texted us and said we got to
do this elon thing
sounds like you've got a lot of opinion
or you have a lot of opinions
i got some opinions i got some opinions
for sure uh first let's summarize
what happened and then tell me how you
i guess like how you initially heard
about it and how you reacted to it when
you first heard so let's start from like
all right so the weeks and months and
years ago elon has always criticized
twitter saying how he loves it and i
actually think he's one of the top 10
most followed accounts in the world and
of the top 10 he's one of the few that
is actually actively posting as a normal
person would
and he's criticized twitter for doing
some uh for banning free speech things
like that for basically being too
liberal he didn't ever say that word but
that's kind of what he's getting at
right and about
ten days ago or a week ago he bought
nine percent of the company
and
then he announced that he was going to
join the board of directors and the
weekend after he announced that he was
joining the board of directors he
started posting things like let's turn
twitter's hq into a homeless shelter i
actually lived next door to twitter's uh
headquarters in uh at ninth and market
year a couple years ago and it's
basically like no one's there because
the pandemics shut down that area of the
city and it's full of homeless people
and he said let's shut down twitter hq
and turn it into a homeless shelter he
tweeted
said because nobody's going to work
anyways
because yeah because no one goes to work
anyways boys don't go anyways so he took
it it was two jabs that he took and then
also he said
uh should we create an edit button
button yes or no and he tweeted
basically three or four things like that
then on sunday or sorry uh last on
sunday night he was supposed to join the
board on monday he said i'm not joining
the board and to a couple people or
people who are a little bit in the know
of this kind of granular stuff they said
well the reason he's not joining the
board is when you join the board of a
company like this you can't own more
than 14
and so by not joining the board he can
now buy the whole thing and that
happened on monday it's thursday morning
first they were playing patty cake with
each other he's like you know the news
comes out then it's like the ceo of
twitter perrog is like hey um
so happy to have elon musk on our board
he's the best
um jack dorsey says so glad to have elon
on our board elon says so glad to be on
the board jack you know they're all
playing patty cake and then one day
later or two days later something like
that it becomes
he's actually not joining the board and
he basically goes hostile
and now at 6 00 am 7 am this morning it
was announced that he was going to buy
twitter uh right away when he bought
nine percent of the company i think the
stock jumped 10 the day he did it but
uh its current valuation was like 43
billion and i think he offered to buy it
at 53 building billion give or take i
forget the exact amount but it was a
nice premium not a huge premium but a
nice premium
and here we are now waiting for what's
gonna happen next
and by the way i think jack dorsey i do
actually think he was somewhat genuine i
think the the ceo of twitter was not
genuine that guy doesn't even tweet like
he's not even a user
like have you ever read his tweets like
he just tweets like screenshots of pdfs
he follows me that's all i know and so
he's good in my books perrag you're the
man you have an excellent taste in who
you follow
well that's he might be the man but he's
not like a power user of twitter like
he's like i think i know how to use
twitter better than he does you know
what i mean
yeah for sure you do
yeah okay so he tweeted on january 20th
then february 16th then march 3rd
uh you know before that november 30th so
you know this guy's tweeting bi-monthly
yeah so
like whereas elon actually
gets it yeah
so anyway that's where we are now what's
your take
so i think there's a couple different
things first i want to just say
baller move
i've baller i've been on the record of
saying i think elon can be
kind of cringy with stuff he says in
public i think he's an amazing inventor
i think he's he's a amazing
you know visionary and you know a force
of nature for sure but i think he's kind
of cringy in the way he kind of
uh for somebody who's like you know
trying to be kind of like an engineer's
engineer uh he sure does do a lot of
stuff to like make himself seem cool and
like try to be cool and it just
comes across try hardy to me but this
was not that not just the move i'm going
to read you have you read the letter
yes i have it up the letter is
badass so badass he he created an offer
dude that's so funny that we both like
grew gravity i was good that's exactly
what i was going to bring up was the
writing it was the writing's amazing i'm
just going to read it word for word so
he goes yeah uh so he this is part of
his like sec filing he goes i invested
in twitter as i believe it's potential
to be the platform for free speech
around the globe and i believe free
speech is a societal imperative for a
functioning democracy however since
making my investment i now realize the
company will neither thrive nor serve
this societal imperative in its current
form twitter needs to be transformed as
a private company as a result i'm
willing to buy one hundred percent of
twitter at 52 40 uh 54 20 per share in
cash 54 premium over the day i began
investing 38
uh over what i you know the day it was
announced my offer is my best and final
offer if it is not accepted i will not
re i would need to reconsider my
position as a shareholder twitter has
extraordinary potential period i will
unlock it so that was the start and then
there's one final thing he goes best and
final and he just bullet points a this
is this is the goal this is really cool
this is where he to put his nuts on the
table he goes i am not playing the back
and forth game b i have moved straight
to the end
i am not playing the back and forth game
and moved straight to the end
it is a high price and your shareholders
will love it that's the best slide your
shareholders will love it yeah if the
deal does not work given i have i do do
not have confidence in management parag
sad parag face nor do i believe i can
drive the necessary change in the public
market i will need to reconsider my
position as a shareholder
which it is he says it's not a threat it
is entirely a it's a threat yeah the
biggest biggest threat i've ever it's
like saying this is not a threat it's
like saying like i'm not trying to be
racist but or like
it's like dude what you're about to say
is gonna be racist right don't take this
the wrong way
yeah you're gonna be you're about to be
really freaking rude you're about to get
offended um he says this is not a threat
it is simply a good not a good
investment without changes that need to
be made
and those changes won't happen without
taking the company private but just
the best line of all these is i have
moved straight to the end that's my new
[__] dude i have moved straight to the
end that is my new
[__] sean's new [__] is i have moved
straight to the end
i'm just gonna be using that left and
right negotiations
uh tomorrow's milk road is going to
start with i have moved straight to the
end uh you know when i talk to my wife
tonight and she wants to you know cuddle
and kit no i have moved straight to the
end
if i go if i go in line somewhere i'm
going to stand at the end of the line
i'm going to say i have moved straight
to the end that is my new [__] what a
line
it's good man how about the fact that
he's so
this was basically when he says send via
text
is that literally does he mean that this
is an email that was sent in text format
and then there's voice format or is he
saying this was a text message you think
yeah i don't know what that part was
it's like it's like the file there's
like a screenshot of it and says like oh
it's almost like he's like hey siri send
this to the sec send this to jack in my
address book it's like which jack do you
mean
i don't know what that part was it
sounded like that part was i think he
sent a message either to jack or brett
taylor the the chairman or whatever and
taylor the guy from salesforce who's
brett taylor yeah oh dude i think he's
the chairman of the board
uh josh
and so i think he sent it i think he
sent it to hi i think it was to him and
it was saying
uh here's my offer letter this will be
public tomorrow so i think he you know
was giving a heads up to whoever
i do not think this is going to go
through
and why do you think that
i think that
i okay so uh there's this app called
blind it's very inside baseball app like
typically only uh
the you basically have to have an email
at a large prominent tech company to use
it so i don't even have i mean maybe
hubspot has the ability to use it but um
it's like i used to use this all the
time at twitch it's awesome so like
amazon apple just people twitter [__]
whining
gossiping but you do it anonymously and
they you have to be an employee at the
company to be on there so you know these
are not just randos and they'll like
it's they basically will complain about
stuff that they should be made fun of
like i only make 450 000 a year how's
that how am i able to survive in sf or
what is everyone making right now my
salary is blank post your salary below
whatever and i got some screenshots from
the twitter blind and the people who use
blind i do think are not the
representative of the normal employees
but they basically said that uh like 50
50 thought it was a good idea and 50
thought it was a bad idea um so
but the reason i don't think it's going
to go through is i do think that
management and a large
vocal
subset of the twitter employees are
going to throw a fit enough that it
would make this hard to go through
but it's not the employees who get to
decide i mean what do you mean
well i said the management i think
management could
could
could cause such i don't know what they
could do this is it's a i think this is
like i don't know the exact mechanics of
these takeovers so you know there's
people much smarter than me about this
stuff but
this is something that basically the
the board has to decide and it's like a
share the shareholders if i'm a twitter
shareholder this stock hasn't like
stocks have been basically a poor
performer for like a decade i used to
own this like 10 years ago and um
you know the stock prices you know it
has not been like this up into the right
curve
and you're getting a whatever what is a
premium versus today so today's price is
it's now 45 he offered 54 so
that's what i like 20 something percent
premium don't do public math but um yeah
but
would you take that premium
and and also what he's i think one thing
he said was he would try to retain as
many private shareholders as possible
meaning
you wouldn't have to sell to be in favor
of the vote of of this going through you
could like you know keep your shares or
whatever i think that um i just think
that there's like some like i've read
enough like finance books that there's
all these crazy things like the poison
pill which frankly i don't even
understand a lot of this but there's all
these like weird like you know art of
war type of things that you can do i
think i don't think it's as easy as well
i'm the top bidder i think there's all
these weird things but anyway the thing
here's the thing about twitter do you
know what uh all right so twitter's
market cap as of today it's 34 billion
of course we're like a nice pullback
right now for tech so it's probably 30
higher a year ago but whatever uh right
now it's um 34 billion you know what
snapchat is
uh 50.
about 55.
and here's the thing about twitter is i
believe they have way more users and
it's the center of culture right now
maybe not the center but it is a center
of culture at the moment and their ad
platform is dog [__] it's the worst ad
platform all the big dogs so if they
could figure this out they should be
worth way more the thing is i don't
think elon gives a [__] about ads i
think he's gonna try and figure out a
way how to make money other than ads but
twitter's ad platform is really bad so i
do think that this company twitter is
way undervalued and way under monetized
and they they don't ever innovate
although lately they've done some cool
stuff uh but it's been like you know
10 years 10 years i think right yeah and
by the way here's here's a couple of
takes on the
on the situation so
um
cuban mark cuban came out and he was
like i think uh he goes i think elon is
effing with the sec
he goes his filing with the sec allows
him to say he wants to take a company
private for
54-20 which is like you know before he
used to
sec fined him like crazy because he said
i'm considering taking tesla private for
420 funding secured and so he got to now
do it the official way and just put a
five in front of the 420. um
he had bought the shares a couple months
ago
this is gonna this this news of him
buying and now of the potential takeover
that drives shares up
let's say they don't accept his offer
well then he's he already said i'm gonna
sell my shares if you don't take my
offer so he's just gonna make a huge
profit off of off of these shares right
like he's gonna make
uh you know like i don't know whatever
like i think he bought the shares for
three billion
uh if if he sells it you know for for
you know like whatever 23 game he might
make up close to a billion dollars off
of
just effing with twitter and he gets all
the fame remember we were talking about
our friend who uh our friend alex who
from morningbrew who's gonna
who's talking about buying puppet golf
courses and we were like
this is the optimal spot you said the
announcement you got all the praise you
don't have to actually do it yeah um
get the picture with the check and uh
and post it on ig
don't don't actually give yourself all
the headache and the work of actually
running and owning that business uh so
elon is at that's perfect spot right now
so that's that's one take on it
um other takes uh so you know some
people you know like crypto twitter
basically so there's this uh do you
follow this account punk6529
no but i i think i know who he is i'm
actually gonna click file now what is it
punk what so punk 6529 so this guy's one
of the like best twitter accounts to
follow he sort of like
posts these kind of like thought leadery
things about crypto
yeah i know this guy he's great
he's great he's i think in a very short
amount of time like a couple months he's
built you know he's got 320 000
followers now because he's just had like
really good takes on things
um
uh on things like this and he he said uh
what did he say he goes
he said something like you know um
he's he's basically like you know
twitter should be a protocol it's a
short messaging protocol
and it doesn't need to be owned by a
single company nor does it he says if
you're excited about elon taking over
twitter or upset about elon taking over
twitter well both of these are the exact
same problem our global short messaging
internet protocol should be completely
unaffected by who's the ceo of some
random company in california
in that same spirit let's talk about you
know what what a future you know
protocol like this could be and i think
that's one of the like
that's not like what's going to happen
here but i think i think it is like no
one company owns email for example right
but but which is a protocol for sending
messages that are long form and but one
company does own twitter protocol and
because of that you know
you can't just choose like if this was a
protocol you could say i want to use the
client that has no algorithm i want to
use the one that has a really tight
algorithm and shows me nothing no no
right-wing stuff you would be able to
have way more choice as a consumer and
way more companies would be able to
innovate and build on top of twitter if
it was a protocol not a single company
so kind of his that doesn't matter who's
in charge i don't even think that's
logistically possible at this point
though or is it
uh
not really for twitter it's like almost
like it's easier for the next thing yeah
right that's what i mean jack dorsey has
said he's there's a project called blue
sky which is the idea of like turning
twitter into a decentralized protocol
but like who knows like how realistic
that is and how much of that is just
like you know lip service um so we're
working on it and like you know right
check in in five years and see how it
goes let's talk about this angle here
which is actually maybe the most
interesting which is a
best troll ever
so like this guy's like a child and it's
some of it's not funny this one is very
funny but b i actually think and i think
paul graham said something like this
this i'm not convinced that this would
be good for twitter but i think
definitely there's a for sure
possibility uh that it could be good for
twitter but i think there's a for sure
certainty that this is horrible for elon
musk
consistently the guy makes decisions
that are funny and cool and leave people
like shocked that uh they did that but
it's kind of like eating an entire
orange including the peel it's really
funny and hilarious that you actually
did it and we're gonna laugh about it
forever but i'm shocked that i do a guy
in college you ate an entire orange and
an entire lemon one time in one sitting
including the peel and i'm like that's
hilarious that you've done that i have a
story but now forever but that's gonna
suck for you for a while and so that's
kind of like what this is like this is
gonna be bad for elon for a long time
this is not gonna make his life more fun
this is gonna make his life uh
significantly worse significantly harder
so much more pressure this is not a
smart move for his personal life
well
the the point he's at right now is
brilliant because what does this say
about elon this says
number one i'm super rich i could just
buy twitter how about that uh somebody
tweeted out they go elon said um i okay
you know you don't want me on your board
okay i won't have a board seat i'll have
all the board seats
right so so so that's one piece which is
like
if you in case you forgot i'm way richer
than all of you um okay second thing is
why are you doing this elon are you just
you just want to own it have more power
like think about when jeff bezos bought
the washington post or whatever it's
like
uh what are these billionaires trying to
do they're trying to control us elon's
is like these tech companies are effing
it up which that's already the the way
that a lot of people believe is that
these tech companies have too much power
or too much control they're shaping the
narrative they're they're not free
speech so he came out as
i'm doing this for free speech
it's like ah how are you gonna argue
against free speech right like
you know raise your hand if you're
against free speech and so he virtue
signaled free speech on top of it
uh he did it in like a bold and baller
way where it's like gonna give him like
way more attention and fame and a bunch
of reasons why people will talk about
him
and he's going to make money from it you
know just by like buying the shares
beforehand then creating all this ruckus
and then like you know being able to
sell out if he says oh well i didn't get
it you know um so so i think and he can
kind of be the underdog if like yeah you
know they
the powers that be wouldn't let me do
what i wanted to do i was gonna make
this [__] awesome but uh you know they
they wouldn't let me do it they tried to
they tried to squash me dude how about
the fact that we just did an episode
where we recapped the milk road where
uh you
where peter thiel had this like
outlandish headline where which it might
be true no i don't actually don't think
it's i think he was joking a little bit
where he said warren buffett's a
sociopath and he went to list about all
the reasons why warren buffett who
called him hold on he called him the
sociopathic grandpa in omaha
yes who but like warren buffett his
stereotype and it's probably actually
not true is that he's this nice old man
who's just oh shucks i just happened to
do it whatever and peter thiel is this
evil guy who causes like old grandpa a
sociopath and then you've got elon who
does the craziest [__] on earth imagine
these guys when they're
25 30 years old and they had a little
something but maybe not like that much
and
what type of fun would it have been to
be in the same room with these [__]
[__]
who are who are it's like the perfect
combination of like capable enough to
pull it off crazy enough to think it's
funny and uh
it's just all this perfect combination i
can't imagine being around these guys
when they were younger
yeah exactly ben pull this tweet up so
he's at elon right now as we're talking
he's at ted
and uh you know who's there uh is our
boys
our boys
andrew jack so he's at ted right now
he was there to talk about whatever
spacex tesla whatever dude but of course
yeah of course you know uh it's a it's a
30 minute talk about twitter and so ben
can you pull this link up in the in the
screen share we should watch this this
is elon musk talking about his plan b
if the deal doesn't go through for
twitter so i i haven't watched this
video because it's how this just got
tweeted out just now so i want to hear i
want to live react to whatever he says
here seconds
do you while ben's finding that clip
pull it up then but while ben's finding
that clip do you think
so like
i don't buy like that nice stuff but
like let's say like i see a car that i
like and it's like 50 000
and i'm like yeah i'm just gonna buy it
and i'll figure out how to insure it and
i'll figure out where i'm gonna store it
after i'm buying it like it's kind of a
big deal because it's like a fifty
thousand dollar thing but like it's not
gonna kill me do you think that elon is
thinking about it like i would think
about like a fifty thousand 000 car or
is this like um
like how well how thought out do you
think this is
well let's let's look at this so elon
net worth right now is 265 billion
dollars i think yeah but he can't i
don't think that i don't i don't think
that like that's entire that is true in
a sense of a net worth but he definitely
has a lot of debt because he's got to
sell
i mean it's not like that liquid i would
think
so
even if we don't know all the details
and we don't know how we don't know all
of his personal financial situation but
let's just take the high level numbers
for a second
uh that's
i think it you know like whatever
roughly 20 of his net worth that he
would be putting into this so that's a
lot
you're worth 10 million dollars is you
buying a two million dollar
asset right the difference is is that
you only have eight million if you're
worth 10 million left which is a lot but
like you're not gonna go and buy a bunch
more two million dollar things with elon
you still have
70 or 50 or billion yeah yeah
you have
whatever like 200 billion to fall back
on at the end yeah or whatever it is we
have this clip i want to see what he
says i don't know if this is going to be
good because it just happened just now
but ben let's play this and i want to
hear it
but the truth matters to me a lot
really like
sort of pathologically it matters to me
okay so so
you don't like to lose if in this case
you are not successful in you know the
board
does not accept your offer you've said
you won't go higher is there a plan b
there is
i i think we i think we would like to
hear a little bit about plan b
for it for another time i think
another time yeah all right
[Applause]
i
that that's a nice tease all right so um
that's great nice
[Laughter]
well played well played in that in that
case i don't know the plan b could be
right like launching his own um
launching his own thing i think he's
probably i don't think i don't think
that would that's a good plan b
twitter is is you know it's really hard
you know like how many people say
they're they're gonna create a social
media product and how many people try
and how many have worked so a lot try
everyone tries when they first start and
there's like three
right right tik tok youtube
facebook and
instagram and
you know what i mean there's three
yeah i i do think it would be very very
hard this would be much better as to buy
the existing asset but how's trump's
things doing what's it do you know what
the i mean it's like horrible right i
downloaded it because i was like i gotta
see what's going on on this thing but uh
i haven't spent too much time on it it
was like crashing like crazy like the
first day so yeah so social i don't
think building is possible maybe that's
the plan b maybe he's gonna be like hey
everybody
truth social that's where we're going
right because then you get the trump
stands and the elon stands together
together that's a lot of people who are
like
devoted followers of those two the
problem is they hate each other
and also
elon doesn't care about making
conservatives happy he cares about
trolling so if you only have your own
audience on there it wouldn't be very
fun
right you know what i mean he he he
doesn't like getting people cheering he
like he likes pissing people off or
ruffling feathers and the thing about
the truth i you know what i think that's
rooted in i think that's rooted in his
father lying to him and so elon's dad so
listen
you went you went there daddy issues
it all comes back to daddy issues
everything i think not everything i
think that most things in life are
genetics and then the other half is
things that happen to you from ages like
zero to four
and i that that's really i mean
someone's called he's young
what was he lied to between maybe ten
how would we even know maybe ten but i
do think like things happen when you're
two and three like like it actually
impacts you but let's go up to ten
um and i think that like he's had a
troubled relationship with his dad and
his dad just wasn't around and i have a
feeling there's a world where his dad
was like i promise i'll be at this game
i promise i'll do this or like you know
like you know i'm working on this huge
business deal it turns out he's like
unemployed and he or he doesn't show up
to the game i think that there's like
something like that that has happened
that he's like obsessive compulsive
about the truth i actually do believe
him when he says truth
hmm
what did his wait sorry what did his dad
lie to him about
i'm just made that up i don't know but i
know that his dad
his dad
his dad wasn't around like his dad like
was uh
he left his mom and like he wasn't very
present in his life and i think he was
kind of uh rude to his family and i'm
just guessing like there's a world where
like he's like a just one was kind of an
[__] and was kind of messing around
uh and just not doing it
for sure the things that you value come
from your experiences like you know
people who value authenticities because
they've dealt with inauthenticity people
who value you know family is typically
because they've had either great
experience as a family or
uh terrible experiences with the family
and they want to rectify it right so you
definitely are shaped by that so if he's
telling us
you know i'm sort of like what i don't
know what he said that like i'm
maniacally or whatever he said like you
know maniacal about the truth um i think
he said i think he said he said
obsessive i think i think he says like
or he said something like to it's point
it's almost a problem that he goes i
care about the truth
and like you know okay some percentage
of that is just again virtue signaling
but you know let's take him at his word
for it um
you know let's be clear what does he
think is happening so you know like
um what is untrue you know like it's
like free speech cool people gonna be
able to say anything those not those are
not necessarily going to be true right
um it's just this belief there's a
belief that
you know the answer to bad speech is is
more speech not censorship so you know i
i get that um but i'm not sure really
what his ideas are right like if you if
you look at the list of ideas i forgot
what um
i saw this screenshot of elon's uh
elon's
twitter
uh ideas let me see if i could find this
real quick i don't even i think that
like i i'm not well versed in like the
political scene of twitter and like i
understand why people want free speech
obviously i know the donald trump
example and that's just like an example
everyone hangs on i don't know tons of
other examples one of them being
this hunter biden story which i don't
even remember what the story was but i
know the new york observer which is a
conservative paper in new york they said
hunter biden i think it involved
prostitutes i think it involved drug
addict being a drug addict things like
that they published it twitter suspended
them and turns out a year and a half or
two years later it was true and new york
times wrote a very similar story saying
the same things happened they posted it
and they weren't banned and i think that
there's a handful of examples like that
that people are pissed off about but i'm
not sure if it's like
rampant other than i mean but
one could argue it is rampant the most
popular if the president can't use
twitter
yeah i think that's probably like the
strongest uh
the strongest like you know example hold
on uh okay so i'm just gonna read this
out loud real quick uh because all right
here let me uh
yeah let me read this one here's a list
of of what elon has tweeted since um
you know since he kind of announced that
he what he was going to do and
before he uh left the left the board he
goes
the first one tweet was
vote to remove the w from twitter so
just tinner and his poll options were
yes and of course god that's so stupid
that's that's that's kind of a cringe
joke
exactly
proposal number two turn hq into a
homeless shelter number three eliminate
ad revenue number four just say that
twitter is dying number five
overhaul the blue checkmark policy
number board with that he said he was
gonna uh smoke weed at the next board
meeting oh my god he posted a meme of
him smoking weed at joe rogan uh at the
next board meeting
uh the next one an edit button
next idea and they just put this in
quotes free speech
like
there was no idea of how or why or what
you know like just free speech and the
last one was open source twitter
algorithm so like you know so the people
who are like you know elon's gonna save
um
you know i was gonna save twitter it's
like well if you
if you pay attention to the uh the ideas
that he had
uh
they were not the most earth-shattering
ideas between our tenor homeless shelter
you know quote unquote free speech what
you know what were these ideas our
friend nikita who uh
seems like he knows what he's talking
about with some consumer apps was like i
you know maybe i like elon maybe i don't
but
running a car company and creating
paypal and a solar business is a lot
different than like the kind of art that
it takes to create a consumer tech
product like twitter and i totally agree
with that you know like think about this
like when someone's like well we're
gonna create this thing that you could
only rate 140 characters nine out of ten
normal people would be like what f that
let's make it so i can write as much as
i want or let's just make it so anyone
can edit it and do all this other stuff
and they're like no no we're gonna do
this weird thing
it's kind of like vine like you only
have four seconds to make a video four
seconds no one no one can do that it's
like no it's actually and it creates a
whole art out of it you know what i mean
and so i think twitter will or elon
could potentially be a little bit too
rational and logical to create the magic
of uh of twitter
so i have the complete opposite take i
think if the guy can land a rocket
re-land a rocket on its butt in the
middle of the ocean and he can make
electric cars that are awesome
pretty sure he could like you know
figure out the social media thing now
the problem is he's still doing those
other things like [__] albert
einstein ain't going to create youtube
you know what i mean like he's not going
to create it he doesn't need to create
it he's just he's a he's a he's a leader
and he's a first principal thinker you
know like
do who do i have more faith in perage or
elon i have more faith in elon than i do
for peridot well yeah but that guy ain't
running that guy's running it he ain't
he's a video he's just making sure that
his trains show up on time he's not
building the train well that's the
problem right like you know that's why
it's plateaued that's what user growth
was like 300 million monthly active
users like whatever five years ago now
it's like 340. it's like it hasn't grown
uh much at all plus you know other
problems of like hate scams and other
stuff so
my take is is that this is the ultimate
example of social media ruining
everything so like
think about in your in my day like um i
know for me how much time and
productivity from like useful awesome
activities i i could be doing i'm just
checking twitter i'm on tick tock and
whatever you know social media is this
like distraction time suck it's like
damn this guy's trying to make us
multi-planetary and like self-driving
cars and like get us off of fossil fuels
and he's getting distracted by social
media he's just doing it at the biggest
scale like not just using social media
he's like i'm gonna buy it then i'm
gonna have to fix it
and it's like dude no no just just do
the thing where you help us like go to
mars and have self-driving cars that are
electric like those are the useful
things solving social media is like just
another distraction just done at elon
scale if he dies in the next five years
would you be surprised
i would not be surprised
i would not be surprised either do you
think that would be the way that that
would that's does this story have to end
that way like no i don't think he's
gonna die that i don't think he's gonna
die like you know low probability but i
do think that um
it would turn him into like the greatest
cult hero ever well it's kind of like
uh you know everyone talks about tupac
and i've got tupac in my background here
i love tupac you know he died when he
was 25 he was only 25 and people talk
about this guy being like yeah a lot of
people don't know that he was 25 biggie
was 24 okay and so people are like oh
they're the best rappers ever and i'm
like well they didn't really have that
long of a career so like jay-z and m and
eminem they've done it for like you know
20 years now so they definitely have and
and and but the reason we say he's the
best ever is because he died young and
it's like all the potential so in some
way i'm like that's elon can do the same
he should go out on top maybe and then
we'll remember him as being the best
i mean would you want to die and be the
tupac of newsletters or what
no i wouldn't want to no but i'm not
elon you know there's two things i know
in this world like that you know there's
crazy guys in the world like elon and
the second thing is i'm not one of them
that's
that's what i know is is there's weirdos
like him and i ain't it
we should end it on that just to
reiterate your angle sam you're of the
opinion that elon has daddy issues and
you hope he dies is that correct
um
uh to the first point 100 his dad daddy
issues yeah show me a successful person
i'm gonna show you a [__] up dad for
sure
without a doubt okay the second thing do
i do i hope he dies 100
no do i think it will be an even better
part of the story yes unless he has some
like um what's the guy's name uh the
rich guy who uh created the airplane
that uh
leo had a movie
howard hughes unless he has some kind of
weird howard hughes thing where it
becomes even more uh or jd salinger
where he just disappears and it becomes
even more of this like mystery then yeah
i'm on board with that but if he just
gets old and he just begins like peeing
himself and dies i'm like oh [__] like
you can't he can't go out that way
yeah yeah that's actually a better
question which was what's the right way
for elon to go you know like
heart attack nah just he was overworked
and stressed nah that's that's for
that's for the common man well dying on
mars like crashing exactly that's a
great way he's got to be the guy who
goes to mars
dies in the process taking taking men
farther than they've ever gone before
that's got to be the way he goes just
drifts out of space or he just
disappears and just like no one knows
where he is and he's just he's he lives
in a uh a trailer in rural and he has to
go when he goes out he has to say he's
satoshi nakamoto also he has to just
he's the smartest move he could do right
if i'm his pr team i'm like listen elon
before you go we need to
claim the satoshi thing
uh
that's just the cherry on top of your
legacy is if you were satoshi and
there's no way to disprove it if you're
going to go anyways so
um
so that that's the last little little
thing he should do on his to-do list on
the bucket list before he kicks it dude
this is awesome all right that was not
where i thought we would end it with him
dying that's a that's a good impromptu
episode i think ben what do you think
loved it i loved it i um
i think uh i think it's a bad investment
i but i think elon's having fun if you
had as much money as he had why would
you not spend your time just having fun
i think he's having fun i don't think
he's having fun i don't think he's
having fun i think he's doing it as an
investment you think this is a strategy
i think that he's kind of playing the
role of a court jester
where
he's laughing on the outside and it
appears to be fun and everyone's
laughing with him
uh but also he's crying on the inside
i think i do i i do not think that his
life is enjoyable in any sense of the
word
i don't either but i think he's getting
enjoyment from this probably
yeah like it's like a i think it's a but
i think it's our version of like
when you tweet something funny or i
tweet something funny i also like
like giggity like i'm like i'm like
quagmire family guy like giggity that's
hilarious but like it doesn't it's not
like i'm happy like three days later
from that and feel like content
right right yeah you're saying he
doesn't come across like a content happy
person and hell no said in many
interviews the to that extent you know
things like you wouldn't want to be me
that's not what uh you know a very happy
content person says okay great or i will
find death as a relief right so those
are pretty you know
as strong as it gets you don't have to
read between the lines there uh but to
ben's point i do think that he gets off
on being you know the class clown
the guy who gives the middle finger to
the to the to the system right he's
he's taking fu money and he's saying fu
so you know he's he is enjoying i think
the stunt aspect of it and i don't think
he's doing it as an economic investment
i think he's he's doing it as a
combination of maybe 20
stunt
publicity stunt and maybe 80 mission and
maybe i'm wrong on those sliders maybe
it's more like 50 50 or you know 80 20
the other way i'm not sure i i think
it's 80 mission 20 stunt not an economic
investment
but i use the most economic as we say on
the on this on my first million podcast
uh yeah we're big on being post-economic
uh
late stage capitalism that's what we're
known for but i do think like you look
at jeff bezos who bought washington post
i don't know he paid like a billion for
washington post oh i think he paid 200
million dollars to 200 million okay 200
million nothing but at the same time he
got nothing like washington post
gives you a voice i guess
but like you don't even have full
editorial control and
like it could if you wanted to but he
could if he wanted to i think what he
got is a little different i think at the
time that was seen as like
cool power move like we all know about
that so it did work in that sense the
second thing he got was
something many rich guys have
just vanity you know collectibles items
ah yeah i own this i own the you know
this farm i own this basketball team i
own i own these things you've heard of
um that there is a sort of rich guy toy
toy chest thing
i agree it's like owning a sports team
it's like a journalism sports team but i
think like from the functionality
standpoint of like actually being able
to have a voice
like
buying twitter is sort of the same thing
but he's getting the only voice that
matters like he's getting the only thing
that can actually
drive and change public opinion if he
wanted to to pull that move
how much is like cnn
hmm good question
what's the parent company
[Music]
well i think they just merged did they
uh
maybe between five and 10 billion i
would guess
yeah look up
look up a lot of bags for your buck
but news corp which is the one so
basically rupert murdoch started fox
which is uh he started this one company
that
recently uh had to separate because it
was a monopoly on news and those two
companies became news corp which
basically owns fox news and fox news
affiliates and then 21st century fox
which is like the movies and tv shows
and collectively that value is like
i think a hundred
no no uh
or 50 13 billion
uh both of them combined no
maybe i don't have the second one what's
the news corp news
class a is 13 billion that's the least
valuable or the less lesser of the two
what's the more valuable one fox 21st
century i think that's what it's
called i don't know dude i think this is
the one
uh fox corporation fox
okay i don't know if this is the right
fox but fox corporation 30 billion yeah
that's it that's it so fit uh 43 total
yeah
yeah this is the right one and they're
way more popular than cnn so uh yeah cnn
can't be that expensive but who the [__]
wants to own cnn
these dudes who want to own washington
post and twitter right why not dude you
know how many people watch cnn uh at any
given point like they're real-time
viewers it's like sometimes as low as
tens of thousands of people like it's
not it's it's not a significant amount
of people that are watching at any given
point there's chicks on twitch doing
asmr that have more viewership than cnn
like in the middle of the afternoon
yeah that's what i'm saying like
cnn like not really but it's hilarious
that i said that i mean
there's like cool [__] like anderson
cooper is pretty cool but like it's just
like [__] dentist like you listen to
it when you're at the dentist like it's
not like particularly when you're
trapped in a chair being tortured yeah
it's like shooting situations and like
going to the dentist or like the only
times that i've got like cnn on or when
you go to like do you ever go to the do
you ever get coffee in the morning in
fox or at a mcdonald's they always have
like fox playing in the background
that's like the only time i like see the
news that's hilarious did you see the
cnn plus like fail it failed yeah dude
what do you expect like you can't just
like put a plus and then a paywall on
like the [__] that no one cares about
and hopefully they automatically do
courts shut down their paywall today too
it was the same thing it's like you
can't just call quartz pro and expect to
get more money because the main course
already sucks
you know what i mean like you're just
putting a bow on like pay for it though
yeah like you can't put a bow on a pile
of poo and it automatically isn't a pile
of poo
but that's basically what a lot of these
companies do and it's not the right move
yeah the plus thing is just like a dead
giveaway it's like that's a tell a plus
or pro
[Laughter]
um all right that was good
you